The following table contains
the first five terms
of the given Pattern
A. Generate Pattern
B according to this rule.
For every term of Pattern
A-- so they give us
the terms of Pattern A
here-- multiply the term by 3
and add 1 to get the
corresponding term of Pattern
B. Then graph the pairs
of corresponding terms.
So for every term in Pattern A,
we want to multiply by 3 and 1.
So if we multiply
0 by 3, we get 0.
And you add 1, you get 1.
If you multiply 1
by 3, you get 3.
And then you add 1, you get 4.
2 times 3 is 6, plus 1 is 7.
3 times 3 is 9, plus 1 is 10.
Remember, we're just
multiplying by 3 and adding 1.
4 times 3 is 12, plus 1 is 13.
So those are the corresponding
terms for Pattern B.
And then they ask
us to graph them.
So let's try to
graph these points.
So when Pattern A is
0, Pattern B is 1.
When Pattern A is 0-- so
this is Pattern A equaling 0.
That's our horizontal axis, the
value of Pattern A-- Pattern B
is the value of
our vertical axis.
Pattern B is 1.
When Pattern A is
1, Pattern B is 4.
So when Pattern A is
Pattern B is on
the vertical axis.
When Pattern A is
2, Pattern B is 7.
When Pattern A is 3,
Pattern B is 10, so 3
in the horizontal direction.
That's our Pattern A value.
And our Pattern B value is 10.
And then, finally, when Pattern
A is 4, Pattern B is 13.
Now, let's just look
at these patterns.
We see Pattern A is
increasing by 1 each time,
while Pattern B is
increasing by it's-- well,
Pattern A starts at
0 and increases by 1,
while Pattern B starts
at 1 and increases by 3,
which makes complete sense.
It makes sense that it starts
at 1, because all of these,
you multiply by 3 and add 1.
So you start at 1.
And then, the fact that
we're multiplying by 3,
that's what's leading to the
distance between these points
being 3.
So let's check our answer to
make sure we got this right,
and we did.